i know that sounds stupid don't make a
business plan that's what's going to
empower you to understand all the cogs
that make these different businesses
work
what advice would you give to the
influencers who really want to blow up
the business side
of their business
believe nation marshall sandman in the
house
i'm going to read off he's he's
officially the managing partner of
animal capital
the first gen z focused venture capital
fund
we're going to talk about how to make
money as an influencer and also all the
fun stuff that you're doing behind the
scenes
how do you introduce yourself when
you're talking to people uh
that's what i say and then people have
absolutely no idea what it means
right and then it takes there's like
i've worked my
my like where how the hell did this
happen down to like like a
hot 150 second really fast explanation
and then we
we take time to go to go deeper but it's
i mean it's a
animal capital is a 15 million dollar
gen z
oriented i wouldn't call it gen z
focused venture capital firm mostly
health and wellness fintech and consumer
underpinned by three of the most famous
male social media stars in the world
and so is your goal now to
recruit more talent like what are you
invested into what are the opportunities
you're looking at right now
sure so the the the way that it really
works is
um as you know people watching this may
not know
what a venture fund typically does is
pick a particular size company in a
particular
topic or certain subject matter or
vertical and just
invest usually the same sort of check
sizes so for us
we write between anywhere between a
hundred and three hundred thousand
dollar check
into season series a businesses that are
health and wellness based
uh fintech based consumer based a little
bit of media and usually what that ends
up really meaning is
they usually just launched a product or
service or they have it it exists
it works really well and they're about
to launch it um
and so we are we're just finishing the
fundraising bit of it that that's you
know gone
relatively nicely and we're just focused
on finding businesses and i i
say this a little bit tongue-in-cheek
but um it's impact it's impact investing
for profit we
really only like investing in things
that make people's lives better or more
fun
and if it doesn't do one of those two
things or both of those things we're
probably not investing in it
and looking at your background of
helping basically blow up a whole bunch
of different influencers
how does influencer marketing fit into
this so you're not only if you're
getting into fintech you're not just
looking at how do you get
the next social media star and blow them
up is it how do we find great companies
and then use
influencers to spread the message yeah
you're you're hitting on what i think is
like definitely what people consider to
be the sexiest part of what we do
um number one i would say
uh the guys are focused on helping these
founders grow
and sometimes that means that they're
the face of the business
but most times it doesn't a lot of times
what we do with
you know with griffin johnson noah back
and josh richards three of the founding
members of the sway house and
josh is one of obviously the founders of
talonx the management company
is we work with the founders not on them
being the marketing strategy but
what are all of your different sort of
like growth points and pain points so
sometimes it's
being behind the scenes and maybe the
right target
audience is not exactly their demo for
gen z which is like
60 women between the ages of 15 and 28.
maybe it is 28 i'm a 29 year old
white guy maybe it's 29 year old white
guys and then they'll get on the phone
with the
with founders for hours and work through
what their marketing strategy is and
talk about how it's going to or not
going to work
um and a lot of times that's what that's
what founders want is
they want to make sure that before they
go use their gigantic marketing budget
that there's a chance it's going to work
or even if their their marketing can be
ten percent more effective that
hour-long phone call that
five-hour long phone call with me and
josh or me and noah or
just them um can be really really
helpful in that way so
we oftentimes help founders with that
but you know other times
just because you know we've done so much
work and i guess i haven't said anything
about my background i
went to cornell i worked at goldman
sachs for several years
uh i ran a small pool of venture capital
warner media before joining up with the
guys
so between all the brand deals they've
done which is like you know between the
three of them and
probably close to 100 over the years and
all the businesses i've worked with
we could we try to do other things for
businesses other than marketing so if
they're raising money
we'll call a bunch of the founders that
we know and try and help them raise
money and help them get some checks in
the door
if they're a big um direct to consumer
cosmetic brand
and they really want to be in walmart
we've had a bunch of businesses going to
walmart we'd call them people
walmart and say hey you know is this
business a fit for you so
a lot of times that sexiness of what we
do in the marketing side gets us in the
door
and then we offer all of the stuff that
a regular venture capital firm does
it feels like you're offering a lot more
than what a typical venture capital fund
does
we we have i mean we have to there's two
pieces of it you know what one is
i'm i have been doing this for a long
time but it's the first time it's
you know it's it's our fund um
and a lot of times you have to you have
to over perform and over you know
sort of over pr i wouldn't say over
promise but under promise and then
severely over deliver
um so we like to do a lot of different
things
and number two is you know the number
one question i get from investors is
what happens if the guys and and like
fair question right like it
they're you know they're young they
happen to be very responsible they
happen to have made a lot of the right
decisions
but all it takes is one bad decision
right
um and what i tell them is that they've
proven themselves over and over and over
and over again
this is another proof point for them um
you know someone like mark you know we
just opened a production company a
partnership with mark wahlberg a month
or two ago
mark wahlberg has probably one of those
pristine reputations in hollywood
he would not take a bet on josh if he
didn't believe in them and believe that
he was ridiculously responsible so
we need to over deliver because we need
to prove
you know whatever stigma there is about
young people invest and we need to prove
it wrong
and open the door for other people
behind us to do what we're doing
talk a little bit about the business
acumen behind it because i think a lot
of people would see them
they may not be familiar with you but
they're feeling with the partners who
are kind of
always on tick tock always online but
not talking
entrepreneurship you know not going to
hardcore business strategies but
but you can i guess to the smart i see
there's a lot of business smarts
behind everything that was created talk
to me about
the business acumen behind the people
sure
listen i think that number i think first
first and foremost
being you know i think josh is the
youngest of them and griffin the oldest
of
those three united 19 being josh and 23
being griffin
um they have demonstrated a tremendous
amount of responsibility and maturity
and business acumen by saying
okay you know i've come into cash
earlier than i probably ever would have
expected josh's parents are public
school teachers
griffin's parents um you know own and
operate a farm in indiana
uh we're going to bring some
professionals and michael gruen and
marshall
to um you know help us shape this
strategy and help us make some
make something that's going to work and
teach us how to do this um
that paired with we've probably done 400
founder calls
me you know plus them over the course of
the last year it's taught them a lot i
think that they
have learned a lot from me and michael i
think they've learned a lot from their
conversation with founders and they've
learned a lot from the interviews
they've done and they
continue to be extremely hungry for me
you know
and um i guess this isn't uh private
because we're having a nice public
conversation but
as you know as an example josh you know
josh was on cheddar last week talking
about the fun launch and
um he they asked joshua what he was
looking for in his founders
and i thought that was a great question
and josh talked about you know
he partially quoted me and he said you
know i really want people that you know
that we want to go to war with that are
willing to pivot their businesses
because oftentimes the final evolution
of a venture-backed business is nothing
like what
the original iteration of that business
was like and it was moments like that
that made me realize
holy [ __ ] like they're not just learning
things but they're putting them into
practice and
and we're really doing good work here
but and so for me
you know i i have a you know long decade
long background
in you know value investing in the space
and in
bulge bracket banking and whatever um
but they've they've proven that it's not
just street smarts that they're they
want to on the business side
they want to understand what the
difference is between an option and a
safe note and all those things so
i'm just trying to facilitate and make
sure that
they get all that under their belt so
that more and more i don't even have to
be on the calls and i think that's the
best
final version of this is there a company
or
or uh individual that you're trying to
model this after
uh i think that we are the amalgamation
of a bunch of
great other people that have taken
smaller steps in this space
um i think the most obvious one is
ashton kutcher and sound ventures
you know he is someone that was viewed
as like a really good looking really
talented
you know ultra famous actor and model i
think i think he was a model before that
70s show maybe
maybe that's not true what what i think
that's right i don't know i don't know i
think
i think i think he was and now if you
talk to anyone in silicon valley
you talk to founders the actions talk to
they are so blown away by what he brings
to the table
and not just like hollywood connections
and rand
and random people to do marketing stuff
but he
talks about patent law and he talks
about defensibility and he talks about
product market fit and you know margin
expansion in a way that
a lot of vcs don't and he wants to get
his hands dirty so i think that that
what he did by sticking it you know some
structure and a tent pole under what he
was doing as an actor and on the
celebrity side
um i think he's probably our number one
quote-unquote role model
uh and then there's a couple of others i
think what rich kleinman built with
kevin durant 35 ventures is
similar building alongside ultra ultra
ultra famous
forward-facing marketable talent and
then you know lastly i think that the
folks
um and we love these guys we talk them
all the time the chain smokers
who started mantis ventures um they
are a great version of this model and i
i'm a millennial and they are quote
unquote millennials they're closer
they're closer to 40 than they are to
20. um
but they knew what it meant to use their
sort of sexiness and celebrity to get in
the room
and then to drive other value to these
businesses and so there is some
framework for what we're doing but no
one has ever
no one has ever attacked this entire
generation or brought as many
different things to the table as we do
um but if they
you know they're i don't want to say
their crawl led to our walk
their walk and run led to our ability to
walk and run alongside them
i love it so if somebody is looking to
are you taking pictures now are you
are you open for business or that's
happening with families i'm open for
business
i i say this all the time because you
know we've worked with we've worked with
founders since i've started
from age 19 to like 71
i think is like the range of ages and so
a huge part of what we have you know
what we have to do is the fact that
we p josh wanted to be taken seriously
as someone that was going to be a
multi-millionaire
and not just a multi-millionaire that
was investing in being successful
business but was also giving back and
being thoughtful about you know
the community he was existing in since
he was 17.
i need to capture that in what i'm doing
as i look at businesses and bring those
businesses back to the guys to
use their time wisely on the film with
founders so i take
as many pitches seriously as i can
possibly take that said for those
watching
please for the love of god don't message
me on linkedin i'm not going to read it
so okay so we have instagram but this
will be a youtube
video on my channel where do you want
people to go
to dive in and learn more i would say
instagram and twitter are great
um if you want to google what we've done
i think the best you know
the cold outreaches that i respond to
and this is very much the secret sauce
for getting an email back or ending up
on the phone with the guys
is demonstrate that you have any sense
of what we've done already
like if you if you sort of get on and
you and you just say hey this is my
business it's like a
it's like hair gel and i love it and it
works really well and it costs x number
of dollars and i've sold
1100 of them this you're probably not
going to be it but if you say hey i see
that you guys
invested in x business and you help them
with this
video and also this is all publicly
available information like you google me
google josh or michael gruben or noah
it's so easy to find it is like three
extra minutes and it shows like okay
it's worth a 15-minute phone call like
they did a little bit of their homework
um and just you know send me a dm samia
on instagram um twitter is definitely
the easiest way to reach me
um i think just because i just started
my twitter so i have a very small
following so it's a really way to get
good way to get to me but like
my linkedin is a graveyard okay so
that's the hack so we'll link up your
twitter and instagram below you guys can
go check him out in the description
of this video what other hacks would you
tell
people for trying to get on the radar
for vc so demonstrate interest
uh that they actually know what your
fund is all about not just another one
what what are two to three other ones
that you'd really look at
um i mean and i think this these are you
know things that go beyond us because i
think for us
the reality is we're probably like the
most accessible and least accessible
people right you know that's probably
the view is
i i certainly i've got like eight
thousand followers i have no followers
but like
the guys have tens of millions of
followers on platforms you you know a
lot about them in their personal life
but they're probably the heart you're
the hardest people getting touches
that's not true if you spend 10 minutes
looking at josh you know that
josh and i spend almost all day together
every single day a day on the phone
you pick me instead of josh you've got
your chances just went up 15-fold
um the same thing is true to big vc
permits a couple of things
number one is look what they've invested
in and try and figure out how what you
do relates to what they do already
and how you how your business and what
you're doing and your product market fit
fits into the portfolio it's so funny
because i just i can see josh behind the
camera just
walked out in front of my window because
my hotel room's on the ground floor um
anyway um that's that's one is do do
your homework about their portfolio and
how what you do fits into what
fits in with what they do number two is
find
proof points that demonstrate traction
people are making up like different
multiples
and like you know every cpm at one point
was made up like
someone deciding that a cpm was based on
a thousand people is like a really
stupid like random metric that someone
decided on make up make up your metrics
and talk about the way that you
benchmark yourself and what your goals
are in your kpis and how you hit them
and or and then if you haven't hit them
because your business is so new how you
plan to hit them
and so i think there's a lot of things
that people typically don't do also
don't make a business plan
i know that sounds stupid and if you're
in like a marketing class in college you
probably have to make a business plan
just because
whatever the reality is is that your
business is gonna change a hundred times
one page two pages on like here's the
different directions it can go here
our strategies for growth is a lot more
realistic
than this is our revenue for next year i
just taught i just spoke with a brand
that's a consumer package good brand
and they had a specific dollar number
and a specific number of packs of what
they were selling that they're going to
sell in 2021
and i was like there's no way you're not
having me close you're going to be way
above this or way below this
so you're just going from dm because
most vcs are not going to tell you that
they're not going to say okay
don't don't write a business plan so
you're just going from
dm okay i like there's something about
this person i like to just hop on a
phone call
if it's super compelling yes for us most
of the time
i think honestly a lot of our deals
and we've done both we have done deals
with people that are like random
teenagers that slowed into my dms
that were ridiculously impressive the
dms were just like wow like you you just
it's kind of like when you um you know
every once in a while your big
colleges will publish like the most
amazing college essay and you sit there
like man like i probably could have
gotten into a better school if someone
had showed me how crazy
whatever and outside the box things can
be um
most of our deals end up coming from um
big vc firms already that have invested
in an earlier round
and think that we can you know lead the
business of some sort of growth
um which is which is a really really
double-edged sword
um because for us as a vc like i i have
a fiduciary obligation to my my
investors
to do the best that i can do to invest
their money to make them money
um and for for me what that means is if
you need us for traction like you want
you probably need something else too
it's really unlikely that we're the only
problem
so do you guys want to be the lead
investor is that the goal for
the businesses you're bringing on not in
this fund maybe in the next one maybe i
mean it's a small
a 15 million fund on the scheme of
things is like the
it's probably like a mid micro venture
capital firm
um hopefully we're successful hopefully
we raise 15 million 50 million dollars
rather than 15 in a few years
and then we'll be ready to lead and have
the infrastructure to do that for us
we really really like being the second
check we also really like being the
first smaller check
and then going back out and finding the
lead investor we've done that a couple
of times and we love doing that
so almost like an angel round or what's
a smaller check almost like
we're like we know they're raising a
three million dollar round and they want
the lead to be a million dollars
we're not going to write a million
dollar check we'll probably cap out it
three to five hundred thousand dollars
at absolute most
um and we say actually this really fits
in with
me i'm making this up this is not a real
life scenario
mabron lightspeed marcy venture partners
andreessen and we go to this place say
hey this really fits in with xyz you're
doing we're going in we're not like
we're not ready to leave with the term
sheep but we're happy to work with you
on your terms
just for the audience so people
understand how often are vcs
partnering up on deals instead of just
doing it all on their own
um bcs like to do it all on their own
vc's really i'm sure you're not you know
those bcs really like to do it all on
their own
i think that what has become um more
market
is to have a vc lead your round and then
get a bunch of strategics and for much
much smaller checks
even smaller checks than those
strategics really want to be at the
table for
if a strategic is like a big family
office and they're really into like
streaming infrastructure maybe like the
the family was built as like an internet
business and made a bunch of money in
1999 so they have a bunch of it
connections and
the streaming and internet space they
probably want to write a million dollar
check too
if it doesn't make a lot of sense for
them to write a smaller check because if
they write
smaller checks they're not ever going to
deploy all the capital that they need to
deploy
but they'll still get into great deals
because they want to write like it's
better to take the small allocation and
not take it at all so
a lot of times these big venture firms
are allowing strategic
strategics into the round for us since
there's no one really like us right now
and i'm sure there will be i i hope that
people copy cat us because we're
so successful that they feel like
there's a big blank spot in the market
to copy cat which i think is
you know a temp of what warren buffett
used to say is that uh
i think he said something like 30 of
pioneers
um or like 10 pioneers like do amazingly
and then like 85 percent of copycats and
then the foul ones do horribly like
i know i'm like completely butchering
the quote but something about how
copycats can be ridiculously successful
we're pretty unique right now and so we
usually get a nice
carved out allocation to do things
alongside the venture funds
because we all we also treat it like a
two-way street in like a two-way
relationship like we are in a
symbiotic relationship where we want the
vc firms to need us and we want and we
don't want to need the vcr
but we do um and do we really like to
see it both ways
well i think it just speaks volumes to
what you're doing in that
vcs don't like working with others and
yet
they're calling on you before you've
even done raising your fun then they're
trying to bring you in on things like it
i think it speaks a lot to your place of
writing the marketplace the reputation
history you have and
and the opportunity ahead yeah i i i
agree with you and i and
listen i i hope all i hope is that what
you know people look around and other
talent wants to get involved in the
venture space and they and i
i hope that this empowers them to do
that and i hope that my phone
and it has i've been really you know
fortunate this way i hope my phone
continues to ring with really wonderful
celebrities that say
hey i'm interested in being on the phone
with founders and understanding how i
can add value in a way that's not just a
social media post
and for me that's the most making money
for my investors and that are the two
most important things
for the influencers out there kind of
watching wanting to play a bigger game
what it's i mean it's been fun watching
your partners do it and also a bunch of
others
become a lot more entrepreneurial play a
much bigger game than just
brand deals for their tick tock yeah
what what advice would you give to the
influencers who really want to blow up
the business side
of their business so we talk about this
in a couple different ways but
if you ask josh or gru or michael grew
in this they'll say they'll
definitely say the exact same thing we
like the model that we were implementing
going into the vendor phone was called
leo
license endorse and own and you want to
have about a third
a third and a third um
and if you're able to fill those buckets
and own a little bit about what you of
what you do
endorse which is sort of a typical brand
deal
and and license which is sort of a
hybrid of the two um
look to own a piece of the businesses
that you're that you're working with
sometimes it makes sense and sometimes
it doesn't the problem is that you need
to align yourself
with somebody and it might be you it
might be that person but
more than likely at the beginning stages
it's not that
that it um wants to partner with you on
the equity side not just your manager
agent that needs 10 of the cash um
because that's where people get a lot of
trouble and we're so fortunate
that josh and griffin and noah have such
a big relationship with talonx the
management company
because michael and josh founded talonx
so they're
they're not worried about the 10 they're
worried about the long-term
economics and that's where people get
caught up is you might be a ridiculously
big supermodel
and you might get 250 000 for an
instagram post
but then what ends up happening is like
one day you just stopped getting those
deals
it just happens and we and and you know
i have enough
you're not probably similar ages but you
and i can both think back to
the two or late 2000s early 2010s and
teens
to people we thought would be famous for
forever and that aren't for that exact
reason
that didn't take the opportunity to
build number two is and this is not in
that leo concept is find a way to
consult with the brand that you're
working for and build a little bit of a
like a
a side business to your side business
because you might not always be the
right face of your business
um and there's going to be a lot of
businesses where you're not and if you
build a reputation as someone
that can help develop a social media
strategy or help develop a go to market
strategy
you can do a a lot that isn't just you
know
broad social media and then a lot of
times it's not just consumer products
you can
you can step into a freaking like
um you could have a a substantive
conversation where you make money with
metlife
about like what's not working with you
know with on their marketing side and
it's going to teach you a lot it's going
to teach them a lot
last question because i know we're we're
hitting the clock um
for the people who maybe don't want to
be an influencer
but want to be like you you know want to
be the guy who doesn't have the tens of
millions of followers but is
the brains behind everything and
instruction deals kind of behind the
scenes
uh what advice would you give those
people um
every single connection is important
every single connection is important
um number two is and i'm
this is such a candid i can't answer and
i apologize but it's just
my i have cousins that are all in their
early 20s
and you want to do some something
somewhat like this and like
like can i intern whatever i'm like no i
can't no i'm gonna take
i'm gonna take applications for intern
like a regular
company um go work at a big
go work at a big company um and whether
that's an investment bank because you're
certain that you want to do investing
or deal structuring and you need to
learn kind of
the groundwork um it doesn't have to be
a big investment bank
i worked for over a year at a little
place called the jordan edison group
um jegi in midtown manhattan which was
focused on media which is what
transported me into this career it
wasn't my time at goldman sachs
there's a million boutique banks out
there that love to teach these
fundamental skill sets go
do that you if you beat enough doors
down i just did this with my cousin i
helped him apply to 145 jobs he just got
an offer yesterday i'm so thrilled for
him
braxton i think he's watching this he's
commenting on this he's moving to new
york this summer
i'm so thrilled and proud of him um but
he beat enough doors down that it
happened for him
not because he was the smartest but he
got the smartest because he did enough
interviews and whatever
that's one and maybe you're not a banker
and that's totally fine
if you know what industry you might want
to go into go to a big company where you
understand where they they have
a marketing arm and they have a pr arm
and they have a product development arm
and find a way to learn different pieces
of that business because
that that's what's going to empower you
to understand all the cogs that make
these different businesses work
and then um lastly and this one's really
really
it's more important than the other two
um you need to have a side hustle
early and it doesn't matter if it makes
no money
it doesn't matter if it is i mean for me
my side hustle when i was leaving warner
media was raising money for a charity in
new york that was making sure that um
kids during coved who would normally get
free meals from their school were still
eating
um i obviously didn't make any money
because i was raising money for a
charity
but like it is so empowering to
meet new people that aren't your nine to
five people
and it opens up your entire world and it
shows you how the world really works
and it is the best way to get going into
like the hustle mindset is just saying
my nine to five is not enough i'm gonna
do just a i'm gonna do five percent more
and that can be ten percent and the
economies of scale how good you get at
your job
and your other thing they'll start to
shift to where you're like actually
i just made my first paycheck i made 200
but that 200
will be so much more meaningfully
meaningful to you than your salary and
it grows and grows and i know that you
know this very well as
those side hustles start to add up i
love it i could talk to you all damon
but if you guys want to follow uh
marshall learn more about him we will
link up his twitter and instagram below
don't go to his linkedin because he's
not responding to you there
twitter instagram there's also a great
article that came out talking about the
new venture that we'll link up in the
description as well
marshall appreciate you man and best of
luck with the new venture
evan thank you so much i really
appreciate you thanks for having me on
much love talk soon if you want to learn
even more about how to raise money from
venture capitalists check out my
one-on-one with dakin
sloss you'll love it the link is right
there continue to believe
i'll see you there if you over
prioritize
making money you're going to lose out i
ultimately think on much
larger opportunities because you're
going to make short-term oriented
decisions rather than long-term oriented
decisions